am samstagmittag sind rund 100 gegner
der korona schutzmaßnahmen in der
hamburger innenstadt auf die straße
gegangen
auf plakaten prangerten sie die
entscheidungen der politik an
mit einem hölzernen sagt trauerten sie
symbolisch um die demokratie angemeldet
waren zunächst 350 teilnehmer bereits am
mittag meldeten die veranstalter eine
verkürzung des demonstrationszuges an
wie ein polizeisprecher sagte dagegen
protest von rund 50 linken sprachen sie
sich für die aufhebung der korona
maßnahmen aus die gegendemonstration
versuchte den querdenker protest zu
stören
die polizei drängte diese immer wieder
zurück insgesamt blieb die stimmung aber
friedlich zu nennenswerten
zwischenfällen kam es zunächst nicht
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren